uh the honourable member for edmonton
strathcona
thank you mr speaker and i think if you
seek it you will find unanimous consent
for the following motion
that given that there is clear and ample
evidence of systematic and massive war
crimes and crimes against humanity being
committed against the people of ukraine
by the armed forces of the russian
federation directed by president
vladimir putin and others within the
russian parliament and be the crimes
committed by the armed forces of the
russian federation include
mass atrocities in the invaded and
occupied ukrainian territories
systematic instances of willful killing
of ukrainian civilians and the
desecration of corpses
forcible transfer of ukrainian children
to the russian territory torture and the
imposition of life conditions causing
grave suffering
widespread instances of physical harm
mental harm and rape the house recognize
that the russian federation
is committing acts of genocide against
the ukrainian people
all those opposed to the honourable
member moving the motion will please say
nay
agreed the house heard the terms of the
motion all those opposed to the motion
will please say nay
motion is carried
[Applause]